Jamie Oliver is proved once again it
takes more than having a famous name
over the door and being able to cook to
make a success of the restaurant
business the celebrity chef has
struggled to make his food outlets pay
their way and now Jamie's Italian it's
twenty-two restaurants and a couple of
other eateries in his portfolio have
cooled in the administrators putting
more than a thousand jobs at risk Jamie
Oliver tweeted I'm devastated that our
much-loved UK restaurants have gone into
administration I'm deeply saddened by
this outcome and would like to thank all
of the people who put their hearts and
souls into this business over the years
a competition across every sector both
in retail both in leisure eating out is
so intense that new businesses are
coming in all the time so that brings
innovation and excitement for us all as
consumers but at the other end of the
spectrum that means those that are
already in the market we really have to
continue to raise their game on the new
James Italian menu across the whole
country Jamie's Italian nearly hit the
buffers last year it was saved largely
due to a 13 million pound injection of
cash from Jamie Oliver himself but now
it seems all he managed to do was
forestall the inevitable restaurant
critic Nicholas Lander says the chef's
bit off more than he could chew as a
restaurateur
it's very sad for the employees but I
think it's quite encouraging for the
British consumer because they've voted
that this place isn't very good
I think it's substandard because his
name is above the door and he has 25
restaurants he can only be in one of
them at any one time so 24 must suffer
Jamie Oliver has always been more
successful on TV and in print then he
has lending his name to other ventures
in 2015 the last of his cookery shops
recipes closed down two years later his
Union Jack's restaurants followed suit
and the same year the food magazine that
boy's name also disappeared and last
year Jamie's Italian closed a dozen
restaurants and made 600 staff redundant
there are Jamie's Italian franchise
across the world which are not affected
by the problems here in the UK but it
may be a while before Jamie Oliver
embarks on another mid-market
restaurant chain business David Bowden
scalings